next question today what would it take
to get Fox and used to turn on Donald
Trump I think that the Fox News would
actually turn on Trump when it's
irredeemably gone underwater for him if
it ever does
we saw some hints that there are voices
of reason on Fox News even outside of
Shepard Smith usually when I tell you
when we do a story and it's hey a grain
of truth was told on Fox News it's
almost always Shepard Smith every once
in a while it's Chris Wallace we
actually have seen some moments were
even unlike Fox and Friends which is
completely a bullet which has completely
blurred the lines between administration
and media propaganda outlet there have
been moments of fact-checking on Fox and
Friends they've been very very small but
they have been there so I actually don't
think that the Fox News apparatus is
ideologically committed to Trump I think
that it's part of their business plan
that this is where people turn to if
they don't want the failing fake news CN
n narrative but I don't believe for a
second that Fox News hosts and anchors
are that ideologically committed to
Trump and I think if he's going down
they will turn on him well I think the
business model has been tied to him ever
since it became clear that he was going
to be the Republican nominee in 2016
sure so that makes me wonder if in 2020
he has a Republican challenger like say
John Kasich or Jeff Flake oh they would
become a little bit more objective and
step back a little bit maybe they would
not become more objective but more
neutral we sometimes talk about the
difference between objectivity and
neutrality maybe they would start to on
anything primary related appear to sort
of be just arbiters and or unbiased
arbiters just reporters of the primary
and not necessarily picking a side when
we know though that sean hannity is
having nightly conversations with trump
he's basically putting Trump to bed we
found out it's hard to believe that some
of those opinion shows where the hosts
are directly tied to Trump are ever
gonna be anything but completely
unabashed feverish praise of the guy
yeah I think they're gonna go down with
the ship
you know I think they all my frumpy gets
impeached or whatever happens like
they'll Stoke with them I think someone
like Hannity is gonna is going down with
the ship if the ship ultimately goes
down so it could happen I don't know
that I'd sit around holding my breath
for it to happen